ok ok prêt je suis prêt
très bien aimants loin
[Musique]
étranger [Musique
] [
Musique]
Je ne sais pas
merde whoa
correct croix boueuse
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est Je ne sais pas
c'est comme un porte-vélos  ou quelque chose comme
ça
qui ressemble à une serrure
comme une serrure ouais ouais d'accord mais je
ne sais pas je pense qu'il va y avoir plus
de ça là-bas ouais nous
commençons juste j'aime cet endroit c'est
un motel
oh c'est tellement  un conseil avec ce look, à quel point
ce truc est boueux et noir, qu'est-ce que c'est, qu'est-ce que c'est, qu'est-ce que c'est,
frère
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas non plus, étrange, il est dans
la boue depuis si longtemps oh, il y a un câble
dessus,
un type de moteur ou quelque chose comme ça,
peut-être Kata  je devrais aller dans l'eau ouais
[Musique]
étrangère
aimant ici oui d'accord
j'arrive
[Musique]
ma passion du bush aujourd'hui juste là c'est
vrai
peut-être un peu plus comme ça
ce n'est pas grand là-bas mec ouais
c'est gros
je  j'y suis tu y es ouais d'accord
j'y suis aussi Google voilà, c'est
quoi, je pense que c'est une moto oh
ouais ouais ouais oui oh on
y va c'est une grosse ouais
regarde ça
dingue ok ouais et  c'est tellement boueux ici
que c'est difficile de les faire sortir du
canal, regardez
bien, vous avez dit que c'était une zone douteuse,
ok, cool, bien joué, d'accord,
continuons alors hein ouais, c'est un bon signe, avez-
vous besoin de bottes,
ok, soyez  gentil avec ces gars,
tu es content ouais oh mon Dieu, allons
chercher le reste de ce truc,
je suis juste vraiment fatigué encore,
regarde ça
oh mon Dieu, je regardais juste ça, je
pensais que j'avais du sang, regarde, j'ai cette
ficelle et je'  J'ai des bijoux ici,
regarde ça, c'est comme un
bouton de manchette ouais tu vois
oh mon Dieu c'est cool avec la
fleur de lys
très français hein regarde cette
musique étrangère
descends ici frérot
oh
mon Dieu c'est quoi ce truc
oh mon Dieu, devrions-nous presque tirer sous
un autre angle de cette façon ouais c'est bien
je sais que
ça allait arriver et puis bon,
ce
n'est pas non, je dois passer par ce côté
ouais super boueux oh ouais d'accord donc nous
devons juste sauter le long des rochers ici
c'est vivant
étranger
oh mon Dieu
c'est toute une épée de rue
c'est la grosse on y va ça dit
bonjour bienvenue en France
ok vous allez devoir rapporter
ça chez vous pour le reste de
votre collection ouais vous le ferez ouais nous
le ferons  ça sentira si bon dans le
van ouais ça sent déjà si bon
merci
ok
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
d'ici
juste comme ça
oh mon Dieu
il l'a
oh ok
sympa j'ai compris
ok
tu vas sur le non frérot ne coule pas
ok d'accord c'est bon d'accord
essayons de le remonter
[Musique]
ok merci
ouais je vois des bulles
ouais
je pense que c'est bon ouais
viens par là
ok ok c'est  ça arrive, ça arrive,
ok, change, ok,
ok,
tu vas ne pas y toucher ouais
[Musique]
c'est un cadre énorme
oh bravo bravo frère oh
mon Dieu,
c'est très lourd
étranger oh
je pense que tu as eu le travail facile en retournant aux urgences de l'
Est,
ok non  c'est faux
je ne peux pas parler aujourd'hui
oh mon Dieu
étranger
[Applaudissements]
c'est tellement gros ok je vais l'attacher
je ne sais pas
oh c'est un caddie ouais mon Dieu
regarde
ouais
oh
l'odeur oh absolument
[Musique]
ok
sympa  coup de feu
relation
oh mon Dieu non non non non non non non non
oh non
YouTube
ok [
Musique]
sympa [
Applaudissements]
très bien étranger
[Musique]
étranger